I am pleased to welcome to the platform
the Honorable Alfred Eva Lucci mayor of
the city of Cambridge in dr. a Bartlett
Giamatti president of the National
League professional baseball clubs and
former president of Yale University dr.
Giamatti will now give the address
[Applause]
good morning
I know that this occasion is a solemn
one it is meant to celebrate the
graduates meant to affirm us in our
commitment to seeking the truth meant to
figure forth the institution's role is
conveyor of that common life we call
civilization
I fought much on our institutions for
learning our universities in the last
two years and today I want to share with
you if I may some of those ruminations
specifically I wish to ruminate on what
it means to be a university president
which I once was what does this have to
do with you graduates well aside from
enriching this moment and of course your
lives in general my ruminations will
eventually prove to be splendidly
relevant being president of a university
is no way for an adult to make a living
which is why so few adults actually
attempt to do it it is to hold a mid
19th century ecclesiastical position on
top of a late 20th century corporation
but there are those lucid moments those
Joycean epiphanies that occur and lay
bare the numinous beyond and give us the
essence of it all I had those moments
they were all moments of profound and
brilliant favor failure but string those
moments of defeat into a strand and you
have the pearls of an administrative
career six months between being named
president of Yale in December of 77 and
taking office in July of 78
I had ample opportunity to receive
advice I listened to many people I
learned for instance for the first time
about the corporate world I learned that
because the corporate world is only
interested in quarterly results it talks
a great deal about long-range planning
very clear to me that Yale needed some
of that too we needed a policy I of
course had no policies I had a mortgage
and I had one suit but I had absolutely
no policy so I cast about I solicited
data and forecasts and projections and
models I did something called a
comparative study I did longitudinal
studies I made a flow chart and I fired
for management consultants I went in
search of policy he got it I was trying
to find what it was that Yael needed
most wanted most and would most
contribute to enhancing our quality and
making me what I knew now I was to be
which was a manager well one night in
April of 78 I was in my garage actually
I was trying to memorize the trustees
names particularly the ones I'd met and
I was crouched between the lawn mower
and of some snow tires and I wrote a
memo it's the first memo I'd ever
written on July 1st 1978 which was my
first day in office I issued the
following memo to an absent and
indifferent University and it read as
follows to the members of the university
community in order to repair what Milton
called the ruin of our grandparents I
wish to announce that henceforth as a
matter of university policy
evil is abolished and paradise is
restored well the reaction was
fascinating for young members of the
faculty in comparative literature wrote
an open letter The New York Review of
Books proving the Milton was not talking
about evil and Paradise Lost he was in
fact talking about irony and the
patriarchal abuse of power
there was a junior near college who was
doing a that summer a leveraged buyout
of a Tastee Freez in East Hampton she
wrote me a very gracious letter and said
I understood that one had to have a
business plan but she hoped I didn't
change things too much before she
graduated and of course there was the
alumnus in New York on Yale Club
stationery who wondered why the heck we
always had to get so far out in front
in September an undergraduate
extracurricular activity in New Haven
called the Yale Daily News wrote the
first editorial about my memo it's
opening sentences for these I remember
them Jamaa tees administration is off to
a miserable start rather than giving us
control over our lives or at least
addressing concerns of students such as
the crying need for a Student Center so
we can make friends or any of the other
myriad of and justices the riddle of
fabric of the quality of life here new
administration is insensitive and
repressive and the future bodes awful I
was one of the best written of the news
editorials that'll be fair of course it
was also the first well since the
students were back and this Daily News
is publishing the medium major media
outlets now had a source for news
because student stringers went to work
and a small article byline special to
the New York Times the newspapers the
the country's newspaper of record
misspelled my name and said a Harvard
professor found a letter from Milton to
his parents in the Yale library
The Washington Post ran a picture of the
memo in the Style section and wrote a
sidebar in a box quoting an FDA lawyer
who asserted that evil had been
abolished three years earlier the
regulations that after all been printed
in the Federal Register and nobody he
knew in Washington thought evil was bad
for you in any case Wall Street Journal
wrote a very pithy editorial pointing
out that fat liberal feet Marxist
oriented eastern universities and
Stanford - we're all in a plot to
undermine the Republic and free
enterprise quote what we need they said
in the journal is not more talk about
evil but some decent courses in risk
arbitrage George will George will wrote
another column citing Montesquieu Thomas
Aquinas Locke and Ernie Banks William
Buckley said Milton quote is all very
well but it is typical of President
Jamaa T and his ilk to cite a secular
authority on evil as if of course though
who have passed any time down in the
Agora or out on the Rialto needed an
authority to know the palpability of
evil in all its camaraderie and liberal
camouflages as you know a university
president as a responsibility not only
for the internal workings of the
institution but also for external
representation and relations as well of
all the moments I remember speaking to
alumni vision foundations and
corporations and mayors and governors
and etc etc the moment I remember best
and I just reminded president gray I
think we met in this office that morning
in Washington was the morning I saw
congressman flanged from the 3rd
district of a state that we will call
grace congressman's office let me set
the scene briefly as a series of dark
paneled Warren's each leading to the
other and as one enters one season a
wall a framed poster of the last major
arts festival held in the district which
is August 17th 1937 there are some
chairs at a table with copies of
Colliers and a telephone it doesn't call
anything there's of course no ashtray
the first receptionist is reading her
high school yearbook and drinking a Diet
Sprite so I approached the other one who
was less busy and I say Mr Jamari to see
the congressman please she looks up and
says well he's either in the district or
on the floor they're not sure while I
sit in the corner by a phone suddenly
the inner door opens in a middle-aged
person with eyeglasses hung in a green
cord around her neck and carrying up an
appointment book a clipboard a stack of
letters a cup of coffee and a Snoopy
lunchbox comes up to me and says he'll
see you right now is please follow me
and she takes me out the door down the
hall to the right through the first door
we come to past a word processor in an
empty desk down a short corridor filled
with overflowing waste backs and should
go sharp right past the young man
methodically shredding what looks like
mail and then into the congressman's
office
well the congressman is sitting behind a
huge desk surrounded by plaques and
awards and trophies and pictures and
laminated
scrolls and six autographed footballs
there are easy chairs a chocolate
colored wastebasket an American flag and
a mother-of-pearl paperweight the size
of a basketball with Republic of China
written across the bottom doctor he says
how are you it's a pleasure please sit
down can we get you some coffee what
brings you to Washington he of course
has not yet looked up I'd like to get a
picture of us I'll find a photographer
and suddenly he's gone out the door and
then he's back with a photographer and
with a tall slim woman about 30 and
slacks blue work shirt denim vest boots
her hair pulled back in a bun doctor he
says this is mrs. incomparable worth my
legislative assistants for education
she'll sit in a flash goes off target
relieves and MS Werth now speaks she
says we think the NIH cuts should go
through we're not impressed with your
factual argument that we can't change
the rules halfway through the game we
think student aid only benefits the rich
and poor and rather than stopping abuse
we'd rather do away with everything we
don't believe in a federal science
facilities fund or in fact in the
nonprofit postal subsidy and given what
they teach in comparative literature we
think would be the height of fraud and
abuse to fund the humanities we intend
to uncap retirement cap Technology
Transfer cut the NSF get rid of the
library Congress and slash the health
manpower Act because we want to get this
country moving again well congressman
beans G says doctor let me tell you it's
an honor having you here we've got a
college in the district they do a
wonderful job education is marvelous
look what it look what it made the
country today we've got a huge deficit
on balance trade a weak dollar
corruption in church and state although
separated of course
it's great to see anything I can do just
let me know while I go back out I go
past the young man shredding past the
wastebaskets past the silent ward
process I'm finally in the Hall I had
not said a word but I had done what I
came to do which is I had my picture
taken
I'd seen a staffer I'd met a congressman
and I'd heard all the issues touched
definitively I felt that our system is
working and the visit remains in the
mind is a pearl there's only one other
than moment that I want to share with
you it's a brief but glistening session
not long before I left in 86 with a
university-wide community-based
self-selected group called the Standing
Committee on special interests this
committee is the special interest group
that convenes to pursue a special
interest if there's no pre-existent
special interest group empowered to
pursue that special interest it monitors
public utterances to see who might be
offended and then it takes offense if no
one else has the time or inclination it
watches power structures it petitions
for redress it gathers rallies assembles
queries at blockades occasionally it
even sincerely with a good heart
assaults in a good cause it is an
extraordinarily hard working group it's
never addressed recently it had taken up
the cause of the inequality of income
distribution in North America the
preservation of all stained-glass window
at Yale and women's volleyball well I
was summoned to meet this standing
committee I said I'd meet them in a
trustee room near where I had my office
they said they weren't sure they could
all fit in the room I said they could
send delegates they said they didn't
trust each other enough to delegate any
of their number I said well it's up to
you they canceled some clergymen in the
city immediately petitioned on their
behalf I caved in and when they finally
arrived there were only seven of them I
said what could I do there's a long
silence what's the issue I was baffled
and finally the spokesperson said we're
really very sorry to come to you like
this but we are deeply concerned
that no one in the administration it's
paying any attention the most pressing
problem of our time which is the problem
of eel evil and the restoration of
paradise what i said i wiii try to solve
that III sent out a memo years ago but
we weren't here years ago said the
spokesperson we're here now what can we
do to make it better and in fact we
talked into the night i suppose in some
ways this conversation and my versions
of the other conversations our
variations on that serious and splendid
conversation that has any great
university anywhere in the country
university today is very different from
the one twenty five years ago or 50 or
100 or 250 years ago and yet it is not
different tough as they are they are
still fragile institutions but at heart
they are still a constant conversation
between young and old between students
and among faculty between faculty and
students a conversation between past and
present a conversation the culture has
with itself on behalf of the country the
university lives through all its voices
and the conversation does not stop there
nor does each of our conversations with
whatever we took away stop either
it is perhaps the sound of all those
voices over centuries overlapping giving
and taking that is finally the music of
civilization the sound of human beings
shaping and sharing warring ideals to
reality and making the world for all its
pain work the university is the place
where the mind learns first how to make
ideas which is the minds most durable
product the university is neither a
paradise no the worst spot we've ever
been in it is a good place which
continues to want to make our children
better but its essence is that give and
take that civil conversation in its
innumerable forms when that conversation
the to-and-fro of ideas is stymied or
foreclosed or frozen when the questing
for truth is
that it must cease because there's only
one truth and it is complete then the
institution in its essence is chilled
and its life threatened the enemy of the
university is finally not descent not
disagreement not disagreeableness
gentility after all is the mark of a
great finishing school not a great
university university doesn't care for
the genteel it cares for the blood and
sinews of ideas and non-coercive combat
with other ideas
I suppose the non-coercive quality is
fundamentally the key it's a combat that
doesn't seek to take a life but seeks to
add energy passion logic and commitment
to the open life of the mind and the
service of a more just society that's
basically the nature and purpose the
norm the guiding principle for all of us
the deniers of left or right the
diagnosticians for whom all illnesses
are similar because all cures are
identical the purveyors of an ism the
dealers and system the myopic for whom
all the world's pain is simply reduced
to their cause the simplify errs who
tell you that they're idealistic because
they've oiled life down to a bumper
sticker or a t-shirt Maxim the
reductionists who pretend to Club global
concerns so it's a promoter personal
preoccupation these are in some ways the
enemies of give-and-take of debate
disagreement of dissent the shouders who
want it now care nothing for exchange
for connection for each of us each to
each working it out what must be fluid
so that each of us has the freedom to
promote another's freedom of mind and
spirit and belief they would freeze
catching us all in the amber of their
dogma some ways they are this subtlest
enemies of the university of the life of
the mind
not because they win the day but because
they remove themselves from debate they
force us into us and them fragmenting
precisely when they most hunger for
solidarity
splintering the very sense of community
they ache to form
you've been counted this impulse here
you would have been any university or
college and you will certainly in the
wider world so all I learned in the
university of my graduating friends that
is worth passing on to you is simply
this do not write off the dogmatist do
not acquiesce in the apocalyptic style
insist on conversation even when it is
not proffered have the courage to
connect the courage to strive to keep
the shouting down and the conversation
open because I think only in that way
eventually will equality of sexes and
races and opportunity finally come only
that way will the homeless get housed
and the hungry fed and the poor will get
work and will the city be rebuilt to
have the moral courage to avoid the
selfishness of self-righteousness and to
assert positively the need we each of us
has for the other that is the real work
of humankind it has begun here and it
will I know be carried out into a life
that will remember how inhumane it is to
leave and other alone good luck
you